but y'all know what it is right of that
gang dude that's it gang gang oh he's in
huh yeah what do black people think
about six nine they like I mean it's
interesting because like he's he's like
he's hike
anytime anybody represents Brooklyn you
know brothers want to attach yourself to
that he's grimy but this the same things
there are Street things that people I
guess got connected with him is the
reason why yo he's locked up now yeah no
I don't wish death or prison on anybody
but you know I'm saying you got it no
something's we happen to when you invite
people to suck your dick yeah [ __ ]
yardas [ __ ] yeah we got yes and it's so
easy for the FBI
and these tactical units to find these
people because all I gotta do is follow
more Instagram yeah you know saying how
do we know Yahoo's gonna be gangbanged
in Chicago cuz you said pull up in
Chicago right you know so I wish the
best for my rip respect the fact that a
kid at his age could stroll enough where
they could put himself in a situation
they got financial gains yeah they
popular in and he made it you may the
same time the same things that you got
probably for it could be to definitely
so yeah for all the trolls I did be
careful do you think he's like the
rainbow Bobby shmurda kinda a little bit
it's murder
sorry it's like no you guys you gotta
take the ERL of sec you can't you can't
do like sh murder in where it would I
don't use it murder
yeah the by murder and Bobby shmurda was
the blueprint on how to get locked up
yeah and they from like the same Aryan
Brook I just don't understand why six
ninety and see it but you know I wish
them wish a whale don't drop the soap
son and you know hopefully you know the
situation where the public can see him
when the care package that I sent you
yeah that's a good point actually we
should make a bobby schmurder uh we
should make uh us we should make a six
nine a package that's him one yeah and
the Austrian Bo's skittles yes what are
you gonna look like when he gets out
though do you think uh there's the
rainbow fade over time
I don't know well if he comes out he
looks like we know something tragic
happen we know that he did he didn't
have so but a rope you know yeah but
just think about it he's only been he's
only been
charge yeah now here's the thing if for
some reason you know none of these
nummies charges stick which is highly
unlikely yeah cuz the feds have 97
percent conviction rate if he beats it
then like he's gonna be mortal man in
the streets yeah you know I'm like you
know and like white kids they could do
two weeks in prison and come out and
have a number one rap yeah below is some
here you see it for hours all you need
to do is get two gunshot wounds you know
I've said you just shot three or four I
think the four I think the number to be
respected streets get shot four times
and you just coming home out before our
beer and you get shot four times so you
could go platon I was stuck in traffic
longer than it was then I was in there
man and that's the whole thing I know
for you to like get a four hours
sentence and drive eight hours when you
got off the bus it was time sir but you
was hard you came back you different
safe I got tattoos oh I feel different
man you should feel different well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you can check
on this video or on this video that's
two different options and you can also
subscribe to the channel check on a new
video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe share subscribe